welcome to the world of business
analytics where data holds the key to
unlocking success in a corporate realm
in this comprehensive video course we
will take you on a transformative
Journey empowering you with the
Knowledge and Skills to harness the
immense power of business analytics
tools whether you're a business
professional seeking to make data driven
decisions or an aspiring analyst eager
to dive into the world of data this
course is your gateway to becoming a
master of business analytics tools
together we will navigate through a vast
landscape of cutting its tools and
explore their capabilities and
functionalities
we will delve into popular platforms
like Tableau power bi and Google
analytics unveiling their hidden gems
and advanced features but that's not all
we'll go beyond the basics immersing
ourselves into Data visualizations
statistical analysis predictive modeling
and data storytelling we will unchart
these sequels to extracting actionable
insights from complex data sets
transforming raw numbers into strategic
Advantage are you ready to unleash the
power of data and revolutionize your
business strategies join us on this
exhilarating Journey as we demystify
business analytic tools equip you with
Real World skills and Empire to make
data driven decisions that drive success
let's embark on this transformative
adventure together having said that if
you're an aspiring business analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply lens postgraduate program in
business analysis from cardio University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be a right option for
more deep details use the link in the
description box below with that in mind
over to our training experts it is no
surprise that business analytics and
business intelligence are two of the
fastest growing markets in the world
organizations today are generating data
at a rapid rate there is a need to use
this business data and make smarter
decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact-based decision
making on the other hand business
intelligence or bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively consider this
example
suppose you sell homemade chocolates
through an online store business
intelligence provides meaningful
insights into the past and current state
of your business bi tells you that sales
of your milk chocolate have spiked up in
Texas the past two weeks so you decide
to manufacture more milk chocolates to
keep up with demand business analytics
asks why did sales of milk chocolate
Spike up in Texas by scrutinizing your
website data you learned that most
traffic has come from a post by a food
blogger based in Texas who like to make
chocolate
this Insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States
using cutting-edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as Microsoft
Excel SQL power bi and Tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth I have always been
passionate about learning new things and
improving my teaching skills about five
years ago I realized that I have a gap
in my knowledge and to fill the Gap I
needed to have skill myself I chose
ingredient my upskilling partner because
of its comprehensive curriculum and its
connection with Urdu University
my name is Carlos vinares
I live in Lexington in the city of
Kentucky in the United States
I am an assistant professor at Midway
University and I hold a PhD in
management human resources and
Leadership
I decided to opt for the post graduation
program in business analysis from Silver
which has helped me a lot in my
professional and personal life
I have been teaching having before I
moved to the United States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
tools it was very difficult for me at
the beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly review
I submitted all my certificates to my
university and based on that my
University plans to develop a class
focus on business analysis and starting
in fall 2023.
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose simpreneur and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
you see how the business works is
changing now and you're Skilling
yourself is quite essential to keep up
with the change everything works on
numbers now data is more valuable and
important than ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing So currently I am on my
MySQL workbench let me connect to the
local instance
so I'll give my password
I'll click on OK
all right so this is my my SQL workbench
query editor so first we are going to
learn sub queries let me give a comment
and write sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
sub query is so a sub query is a query
within another SQL query that is
embedded within the where Clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that I'll
be using my
database that is SQL underscore intro so
I'll write my command use SQL underscore
intro now this database has a lot of
tables I'll be using the employee stable
that is present inside SQL underscore
intro Let me just expand this and you
can see here we have an employee stable
so let me first show you
the contents within this table I'll
write select star from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee ID employee name each gender
there's date of joint Department City
and salary and we have information for
20 employees if I scroll down you can
see there are 20 employees present in
our table
so let's see you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
the average salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query so let me show you how to write a
sub query
I'll write the select statement
in the select statement I'll pass
my column names that I want to display
so the column names I want are the
employee name
then I want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next I'll use a where condition where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees so
I'll write salary greater than
after this I am going to write my sub
query
so I'll give select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees and I'll
close the bracket and give a semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once you get the average salary number
we'll use this where condition where
salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if I run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is 75 350 dollars
now I want to display all the employees
who have salary greater than 75
350 dollars so let's run our sub query
there you go so there are eight
employees in our table who have a salary
greater than the average salary of all
the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary
so if we have one employee whose name is
John
let me
run the table once again
okay if I scroll down
you see we have an employee
as John
you see this our employee ID 116 is John
and his salary is sixty seven thousand
dollars I want to display all the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary so basically all the
employees who are earning more than 65
000 I want to print them
so let's see how to do it I'll write
select
I want the employee name comma the
gender of the employee
I also want the department and salary
from my table name that is employees
I'll write where
salary is greater than
I'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket I am
going to give my inner query that is
Select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is John
So within single quotations I'll give
John as my employee
and end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
John has which is sixty seven thousand
dollars now I want the employees who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see
12 rows returned which means there are
12 employees in our table who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars you see here all these employees
have a salary greater than sixty seven
thousand dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic Model so I'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website I'll just show you the
website me so this is the website that
is MySQL tutorial.org
you can see here they have very nice
articles blogs from where you can learn
MySQL in detail so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website you see here
they have a MySQL sample database if you
click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
MySQL sample database and the name of
the database is classic models all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session if I expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have qriket
customers as employees office there's
orders order lines and many more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table first let me show you the
content that is present inside
the products table first
if I run this
you see here it says 110 rows return
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock Buy price
MSRP
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the details of
all the orders
let me show you
the records
or the dtl Stables has okay so there are
thousand records present in this table
you have the order number the product
code quantity ordered price of each item
you have the order line number as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products whose price of each product is
less than hundred dollars for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables and we are going to
write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here in the order details
table we have a column called price each
I want to display the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way I'm going to do is
I'll write select
product code comma
product name
now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is production order details
here you can see this is the product
code column
comma
MSRP which is present inside the product
stable again
from my table that is
products
where
I'll write
product
code
I'm going to use the in operator
next I'll write my inner query that is
Select
product code
from my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than 100 dollars
let me run this
okay so you can see there are total 83
products in our table which have
a price less than hundred dollars you
can see the
price here
okay
now we learn another Advanced Concept in
SQL which is known as stored procedures
I'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an SQL code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again save it as a stored procedure
and then call it to execute it
so in this example I want to create a
stored procedure that will return the
list of players who have scored more
than six goals in a tournament
so I have a database called SQL
underscore IQ
these are a few databases that I've
already created so this database has a
table called players if I expand the
tables option you see we have a table
called players and you can see the
columns player ID the name of the player
the country to which the player belongs
to and the number of goals each player
has scored in a particular tournament
so I'll write a stored procedure that
will return the list of top players who
have scored more than 6 goals in a
tournament
so first of all let me Begin by
using MySQL underscore IQ database
will run it
so now we are inside the SQL underscore
IQ database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are six players in our
table
we have the player ID the names of the
players the country to which these
players belong to and the goals they
have scored
so I'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this it should start with
a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter I'll write
Amberson ampersand
next I'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name let's say amount to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin I'll write my select
statement
I want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from my table that is
players
where
I'll write goals is greater than
six
will give us semicolon
then
I'll end my
procedure with a delimiter that was
double ambison
next
I'll write
delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space
okay
now let's run our stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our store procedure now the way
to run a store procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure the name of the column is
goals are not goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll edit here as well
now let's create it again
okay now to
call my procedure I'll write call space
followed by the procedure name which is
top underscore players
if I run this you can see we have two
players in our table who have scored
more than six goals so we consider them
as the top layers in a particular
tournament
all right
now there are other methods that you can
use while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so I'll give a comment
stored procedure using in parameter
all right
so for this example I'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees based on their
salaries
so if you have a table
in our SQL underscore IQ database which
is called employee details
I am going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of joint City
and salary using this table I'll create
a procedure that will fetch or display
the top records of employees based on
their salaries
and we'll use the in parameter so let me
show you how to do it I'll write
delimiter
this time I am going to use
forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
SD for stored procedure
sort by
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure I'll give my
parameter
in
I'll create a variable VAR and assign a
data type integer
then I'll write begin
followed by my select statement where
I'll select the name
each
salary
from
my table name that is
EMP details or employee details
I am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
I want to display
limited number of
records so I'm using this
limit keyword and my variable VAR which
I
created here
I learned my select statement
I'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and I'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not here
you have an option to see the stored
procedures let me just refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our stored procedure I'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by salary
and inside this I'll give my parameter
which was actually VAR and this VAR
we have used in limit
let's say I want to display only the top
three records of the employees who have
the top three highest salaries
okay so let me run it
there you go so Amy Sarah and Jimmy
where the top three employees who have
the highest salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement and we
called our stored procedure and passed
in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select statement inside
stored procedure you can also use other
statements let's say update
so I'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of Select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the in
operator twice
so let me show you how to do it
I'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be forward slash then I'll
write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the update salary name
I'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
I'll assign is worker 20
I'll again use my in parameter I'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
I'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement I'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and I'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure if I refresh this
you can see I have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay now let's see
first of all I'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table okay
so we have six rows of information let's
say you want to update the salary of
employee Jimmy or let's say
Mary
from seventy thousand to let's say 72
000.
or let's say eighty thousand
so I'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time I'm going to pass in two
parameters the first parameter will be
the employee name and next with a comma
I'll give my new salary that I want to
so my employee name let's say is Mary
and the salary I want
to be updated is let's say eighty
thousand dollars
I'll give a semicolon
and I'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go if you see this record
for maybe we have successfully updated
the salary to eighty thousand dollars
now moving ahead
we learned to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter so I'll give a
comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
will create total employees as an output
parameter and the data type would be an
integer the count of the female
employees is assigned to the output
variable which is total underscore emps
using the into keyword
let me show you how to write a stored
procedure using the out parameter
so first I'll declare my delimiter
to forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be SP underscore
count
employees
and inside this I am going to give my
out parameter and the variable name that
is total underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next I am going to write begin
followed by my select statement that is
Select I want the
count of total employees
and the output I am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is EMP underscore
details
where
sex is equal to
F which means female
algebra semicolon
next I'll end it
with the TV limiter and I'm going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is colon
so let me tell you what I am doing here
I am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure I am going
to count the total number of female
employers that are present in our table
EMP underscore details so I've used my
out parameter and I'm creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer here in the
select statement I am counting the names
of the employees and the result I am
storing it in total underscore emps
I have used my wear condition where the
gender of the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure
let's refresh this
okay you can see we have a new stored
procedure SP underscore count employees
now
to call it I'll write call
the name of the procedure that is Count
underscore SP underscore count
employees
within brackets I'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
F underscore EMP
will give a semicolon then I'll write
select
at the rate F underscore
EMP as female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first I'll
call my procedure and then we'll display
the total number of female employees you
can see in our table we have three
female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next Topic in this
tutorial on Advanced SQL now we are
going to learn about triggers in SQL
so I'll give a
comment here
reverse in SQL
so first let's understand what is a
trigger so a trigger is a special type
of stored procedure that runs
automatically when an even occurs in the
database server there are mainly three
types of triggers in SQL we have the
data manipulation trigger we have the
data destination trigger and login
triggers
in this example we will learn how to use
a before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the student's rule
number the age the name and the students
marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than 0 our
trigger will automatically set the marks
to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students
all right
so I'll write
create
table
student
now this table will have the student
rule number
the data type is integer
will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or bearing character
size I am giving it as 30 finally we
have the marks as floating type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table now
I'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time I'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is Mark
underscore
let's say verify
I am going to use a before insert
trigger so I'll write before insert
on my table name that is student
next I'll write for each row
if
Nu Dot marks
is less than zero
then
we'll set
new DOT
marks equal to 50.
so this is my
condition first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0 we'll assign a value
50 to that student because usually the
marks are not less than 0 in any exam
I'll write end if
semicolon and I'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command I'll run it
it says trigger already exists so in
this case we need to update the trigger
name let's say
I'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for St
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is Mark and
not marks so here we need to change it
as Mark instead of marks
all right let's run it
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so I'll write insert into student
I'll write
values and give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10
the name is it's a Ruth
and the marks is let's say 75 point
zero
give a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student rule number is 502
ages 12
the name is let's say Mike
and this time I'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the Third
record
for student rule number 503
ages 13
the name is Dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by Dave is
90.
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
these is 10.
name I'll enter as Jacobs
and this time again I'm purposely
giving the marks in negative
12 point let's say 5.
close the bracket
and give a semicolon
and I'll run my insert statement okay so
we have inserted four rows of
information to our student table
no
let me run the select query I'll write
select star from student
if I run this you see the difference
there you go
so originally we had inserted
for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504 for Jacobs the marks
was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because when we
created our trigger we had set our marks
to 50 in case the marks were less than
zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name
in this case our trigger name is
St
I'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
I give this as a comment
okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial Concept in SQL which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
I'll give a comment as views in SQL
okay
now to learn views I am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as I mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so I'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so I'll write select
star from customers
okay
I missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name customer number we
have the address State country and other
information
now I'll write a basic view command
using this customer table the way to
write is I'll write create
View
followed by The View name which is cast
underscore details
then you write as
select
I am going to select a few column names
from my original customer table which is
this one so I need the customer name
let's say I need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number and the City
all right
I'll write from my table that is
customers
if I run this
my view that is cast details will be
created
let's run it there's some error here
because the name of the table is
customers and not customer
I'll give an S and I'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and
to display the contents that are present
inside our view I can write select star
from followed by The View name that is
cost underscore details
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name the phone number and the City of
the different customers that we have in
our table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that I am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table I am talking about the products
table and the product lines table
present inside classic models database
so before I start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description and there's some HTML
description and image
so
I'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing create
View
followed by The View name that is
product underscore
description
as I'll write
select
product
name
comma
then I'll write
quantity
in stock
I also want the MSRP
now these three columns are present
inside the products table and next from
the
product lines table I want the text
description
of the products
so I'll write from
products table
I'll give an alias as p
followed by Inner join my other table
that is
product lines as let's say PL
on
the common column that is product line
so P Dot
product line
is equal to
I'll give a space
PL Dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description let us run it all right so
we have our view ready
now let me
View
or display what is present inside our
product underscore description
View
I'll add select start from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock MSRP and textual
descriptions of the different products
in the table
okay now there are a few other
operations that you can perform let's
say you want to rename a view instead of
product underscore description you want
to give some other name so I'll just
give a comment rename description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement I'll write rename table
product
underscore description Which is my
old name
I want to change this name to let's say
I'll give vehicle description
since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so I'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see I have
renewed my
View
so here if I just refresh it
and I'll expand this you can see we have
the cash details view and we have the
vehicle underscore description View
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel or you can use a command
let's say
I'll write display views
is the comment
now to show all the views you can use so
full tables
where
table
underscore
type is equal to within single quote
I'll write View
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error
this should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
so that you can use the drop command
so I'll write drop
view followed by The View name let's say
I want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view I'll write draw
View cast underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the custom details
view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about Windows functions
the windows functions were Incorporated
in MySQL in the 8.0 version
so Windows function in MySQL a useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my SQL underscore intro
database
so we'll find the total combined salary
of the employees for each department
so first let me switch my database to
SQL underscore
into database
I'll run it okay
I'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we'll partition our table by department
and print the total salary and this we
are going to do using
some windows functions in MySQL
so I'll write
select
I want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next I'll write
the sum of salary
over
I want to partition it by
Department
so I'll write Partition by Department
which is Dept
and I'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go so here we have created
another column in our result that is
total salary and for each of the
employees and the respective departments
you have the highest salary so in
finance the highest salary of one of the
employees was
155 000 dollars
similarly if I come down we have the
highest salary from HR if I scroll
further we have the highest salary from
it marketing product sales and the tech
team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function I'll write
select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so I'll write order by salary
I'll give the
Alias as ronum
we give a comma
and I want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees and I'll
order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a ronum column and we have
successfully given row numbers to each
of the records you can see it starts
from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first I'll create a table
I'll write create table
let's say I'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's see we have in this table the
student ID which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type worker
the size is 20. I'll create the small
table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so I'll write insert
into
demo
values
I'll give 101
the name is
Shane
give a comma
I'll insert the second student name 102
the name is Bradley
give a comma
this time
for one zero three we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
hereat
give a comma I'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated one zero three
next we have one zero four
the name of the student let's say is
Nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student which is Kevin we have
two records
I'll copy this
and I'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you I'll write select
star from demo
if you see this we have a few
information that are duplicated in our
table
that is for student id103 and student ID
105.
now I am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table I'll write
select student underscore ID comma
student underscore name
I'll give another comma and write
Rue underscore number
over
within brackets
I'll write partition
by
St underscore ID
comma
St underscore name
okay
then I'll write
order by St underscore ID
close the bracket I'll give an alias as
runum
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right now if you see here there is
just one student in the name Shane we
have one student in the name Bradley but
here if you see for herath
the second record it says to which means
there are two records for hirath and if
I scroll down there is one record for
Nathan and there are two records for
Kevin which means Kevin is also repeated
okay
now we are going to see another Windows
function that is called rank function
in MySQL so the rank function assigns a
rank to a particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
rank values when two or more rows have
the same rank so first of all let me
create a table
and the name of the table would be a
random name will give it as let's say
demo one
and it will have only one
column let's say variable a of type
integer
we'll create this table first okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table which is demo one so I'll write
value
one zero one
zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
I'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
we have 1 0 4
1 0 5
we have one zero six
and let's say 106 is also repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay
let me insert these values to my table
that is demo one okay this is done
now
if I write
select
VAR underscore a
and use my rank function I'll write rank
over
then I'll
order by my variable that is VR
underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo one
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if I run this there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test time is 2 but
for this value which is 1 0 3 the test
rank is repeated because there was a
repetition of one zero three
so we have skipped the rank 4 here for
104 the rank is 5 now for one zero five
the rank is 6 now
106 again since the record was repeated
twice we have skipped the eighth Rank
and
our rank function assigned the same
value which is 7 for 106 and for the
last value one zero seven the rank is
nine
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final Windows function which is
called first value
so first value is another important
function in MySQL so this function
Returns the value of the specified
expression with respect to the first row
in the window frame
all right
so what I'm going to do is
I am going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and I'll write
first underscore
value which is my function and pass in
my employee name
and then I'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
I'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is employees
so let me run this and see how the
first underscore value function works
all right so in our table
Joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
I'll write select EMP underscore name
comma
I want the department
and the salary
comma
I'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
I'll write over
here I am going to use partition
I am going to partition it by
department since I want to know the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department
and I am going to order by
salary descending
and I'll give my Alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's run this and see the difference
in the output okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for freelance
Jack had the highest salary from HR it
was Marcus similarly in it it was
William
if I scroll down for marketing it was
John a product it was Alice who had the
highest salary similarly in sales we had
Joseph
and in Tech we had Angela so this is how
you can use the first underscore value
function using partition
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on our tutorial
so let me just scroll through and show
you what we did from the beginning first
we learned about sub queries in SQL so
we initially wrote a simple sub query
and then we used our classic models
database which was downloaded from the
internet and also shown you the link
from where you can download this
database here we used two different
tables and we performed a sub query
operation
we learned how to create stored
procedures
so we learned how you can use the in
operator or the in parameter as well as
the out parameter in stored procedure
after stored procedure we learned
another crucial Concept in SQL which is
called triggers now triggers are also
special kind of stored procedures so we
saw how to write a before insert trigger
you can see it here
next
we learned how to delete a trigger we
also saw how to work with views in SQL
so views are basically virtual tables
that you can create from existing tables
we also saw how you can use views using
two different tables and an inner join
and
we learned how to display views how to
rename
view names
how to delete a view and finally we
explored a few Windows function
let's embark on this transformative
adventure together having said that if
you're an aspiring business analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learn sports.jet program in
business analysis from Purdue University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be a right option for
more details use the link in the
description box below
hello and welcome to the business
analytics with Excel course offered by
simply learn this video will give you an
overview about the importance of
analytics in business today why it is in
demand among a lot of organizations and
how you can effectively leverage
Microsoft Excel for data analytics
it is quite clear that businesses must
understand the changing market and
Trends in social media to stay ahead of
the competition and drive effective
business decisions
what can help businesses maintain their
Competitive Edge the answer lies in
business analytics the term business
analytics refers to the skills
Technologies applications and practices
that facilitate continuous iterative
exploration and investigation of past
business performance customer data and
competitive landscape data
the goal is to gain insights and drive
business planning therefore business
analytics empowers businesses to
automate and optimize business processes
thereby enabling them to sustain the
competitive advantage
Microsoft Excel has extensive analytics
capabilities to perform statistical
analysis with the added advantage of
visibility a flat learning curve and
good reporting functionalities Excel has
become the tool of choice to start your
data analytics Journey
did you know Excel offers intuitive
analytics features such as find connect
and shape to model and analyze a
company's data
today Excel comes within memory
technology that makes it easily
compatible with millions of bytes of
data enabling companies to perform the
necessary analysis without being
dependent on Specialized Solutions
additionally features such as power
business intelligence including
powerpivot power query Power view power
maps and so on easily integrate with
Excel
the sandbox-like Excel environment makes
data exploration and deriving results
quite easy it includes features to
perform powerful data analytics
processes with just one click instead of
using a complex set of formulas pivot
tables and manual steps with
increasingly diverse tool sets being
added to excel it's very clear that
Excel is the business intelligence tool
of choice and the future of business
intelligence workflows and is being
increasingly preferred by analysts
reporting professionals and bi people
Excel provides a grid-like interface of
rows and columns enabling users to
organize and format data better the data
can be simple text numbers dates or
other supported formats excel's
libraries span a large range of
functions from basic math to complex
statistical formula it cannot be said
enough that Excel is pivotal to
organizations as it is the leading
user-friendly analytical tool
Amazon an American electronic Commerce
and cloud computing company has been in
business for more than 20 years
it has a user base of millions of
customers
ever wondered how Amazon predicts
exactly what customers want to buy it's
simple or let's just say it's simple
business analytics that involves
understanding the patterns of what
happened in the past to predict what
might happen in the future currently
this is a requirement of every business
simply learns business analytics with
Excel course introduces you to excel the
powerful data analysis tool that will
enable you to collect data and perform
an in-depth analysis of the data to
drive effective impactful business
decisions
designed to build upon the concepts and
procedures in data analytics the primary
focus of the course is to learn how to
use Excel to perform multivariate
statistics and to understand how to
explore experiment and forecast results
with excel's histograms pivot tables
statistics and mathematical formulas and
charts
after attending this course you should
be able to understand business problems
and data sets perform calculations using
statistical techniques
conduct a variety of statistical
analyzes including regressions
covariance correlation and testing
hypothesis
present and interpret the results of
statistical analysis
design Dynamic reports and dashboards
for business consumption
this highly engaging course features
concept videos with exercises which will
Empower you with hands-on experience the
course covers introduction to business
analytics with an overview to different
types of Analytics
statistical and mathematical functions
after each lesson practice and revision
assessments are provided to reinforce
the concepts learned the course ends
with detailed case studies outlining
real life scenarios
simply learned will offer complete
support anytime during the course or
while you're working on the projects if
you subscribe to the live virtual
classroom training you can attend an
ongoing batch and revisit important
Concepts to seek help for the projects
visit the simply learn website
www.simplylearn.com and click help and
support at the bottom of the page to
submit queries you can also speak
directly to the support staff with the
simply talk or live chat option so are
you ready to begin
happy learning
hello and welcome to the lesson
formatting conditional formatting and
important functions in this lesson we
will learn about custom formatting how
to use conditional formatting and
formulas and Implement logical
statistical and mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above Target below Target and met Target
as a data set can be huge and complex
differentiating each value manually
would consume a lot of effort and time
here comes the Excel features such as
formatting and conditional formatting
which enables us to perform this task
easily
formatting as the name suggests helps us
to format the data using different
techniques making the data easy to read
in the required format and analyze them
the right formatting technique applied
to the worksheets can help the users
present the data efficiently conditional
formatting a type of formatting helps us
visually explore and analyze data detect
critical issues and identify patterns
and trends conditional formatting helps
to add patterns and Trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formula Etc
at times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set
Excel provides a large number of logical
statistical and mathematical functions
such as vlookup hlookup and if not rank
quartile and many more that can help the
users to perform calculations ranging
from basic to complex operations
these inbuilt functions help us to
manage data and perform descriptive
statistical analysis
Excel also offers a wide range of
important formulas that help to perform
many common tasks these formula may be
as simple as basic addition or it could
be a complex combination of inbuilt
excel functions before going into
details let us start this lesson by
defining the objectives of the lesson
the worksheets appear more polished and
easy to read if proper formatting
techniques are applied to it we can
format the cells in Microsoft Excel
manually by selecting fonts font color
font size background colors and borders
we can also use numerous predefined
table Styles or quick styles to quickly
format a table automatically this is the
basic formatting in Excel
if these built-in functions do not meet
our needs or do not display the data in
the format that we require we can create
our own custom format in this topic we
will focus on custom formatting in Excel
let's say we want to display one million
five hundred and thirty two thousand as
1.53 M or the 1st of January 2016 date
with a weekday as the first Friday
January 2016. here we can use custom
formatting feature of excel let's see
how we can accomplish this in Excel
in this lesson we shall consider the
following fields from our master table
dates order ID
product salesman region number of
customers net sales and profit and loss
here in the given worksheet we have a
column named net sales
suppose we want to display the values of
net sales in terms of thousands for
example
7164 should be displayed at 7.16 k
select the entire column for net sales
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in the numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cells dialog box appears from the
category list select the type as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number 0 decimal zero zero comma
open double quote capital K close double
quote
here number is the digit holder with
thousand comma separation
each comma after decimal 0 0
indicate divide value by one thousand
the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places
the K component displays a literal K
character to denote thousands
here we can see the preview in sample
box the value shown is 7.16 K
finally click OK button
the values in column net sales are now
displayed in terms of thousands
now let us consider another example of
date formatting
in the column dates we have a date value
written as first Jan 2012. we want to
display it as first Sunday Jan 2012.
first select the column containing dates
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cell dialog box appears
from the category list select the type
as custom
in the type text box enter DD dash dddd
dash mmm YY
here d stands for date m stands for
month and y stands for year
the first 2dd is the date
the next four dddd is for weekday say
Thursday
then mmm is for the month in short form
and YY is for year
here we can see in the preview in the
sample box the value shown is one Sunday
Jan 12.
finally click on OK button
thus the custom formatting helps us in
changing the appearance of the cell
value according to our needs
a worksheet may contain thousands of
rows of data by simply examining the raw
information it would be difficult to see
patterns and trends conditional
formatting helps us visualize data that
make worksheets easier to understand it
quickly highlights important information
in a spreadsheet by using colors icons
and data bars it changes the appearance
of one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than five thousand color the
cell yellow
by applying this rule we will be able to
quickly see which cells contain values
that are greater than 5000 let us
understand this with the help of
examples
consider the given sales table which
depicts the amount of sales done by each
salesman here we want to highlight the
duplicate order ID values
first select the order ID column
clip Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over highlight cells rules and select
duplicate values
a duplicate values dialog box appears
select the formatting style from the
drop down menu in our example we will
choose green fill with dark green text
click ok
here we can see that the conditional
formatting is applied to the column
order ID
Excel highlights all the duplicate cells
with green fill with dark green text
we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains a date occurring and
top slash bottom rules
all these rules work in the similar
format
Excel provides predefined styles to
quickly apply conditional formatting to
our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph
color scales color scales change the
color of each cell based on its value
each color scale uses a two or three
color gradient icon sets icon sets add
specific icon to each cell based on its
value
let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to apply the icon set rule
if sales amount is greater than 8 000
then a green arrow should appear in the
upward Direction
if sales amount is between five thousand
and eight thousand then show a yellow
arrow in the horizontal Direction
and if sales amount is less than five
thousand then show a red arrow in the
downward Direction
to perform conditional formatting select
the desired cells
click on Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over icon set rules and select the first
rule
again click on conditional formatting
select the option manage rules from the
drop down a conditional formatting rules
manager dialog box appears
go to Icon set Rule and select three
icon set rule
click on edit Rule and an edit rule
formatting dialog box appears
by default for three icon set rule Excel
uses the 67th percentile and the 33
percentile rule this means that it shows
a green arrow for values greater than 67
percent
yellow arrows for values between 67 and
33 percent and red arrow for values less
than 33 percent
now let us customize this rule for our
criteria
in the type drop down select the option
as number
in the value reference box enter value
is 8 000 for green color arrow and 5000
for yellow color Arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color Arrow click ok
in the conditional formatting rules
manager window click ok
we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8 000
have a green arrow in the upward
Direction
values between 5K and 8K are highlighted
with a yellow arrow and values less than
5K are highlighted with a red arrow
we can also apply conditional formatting
rule with the help of formulas consider
the given table which shows the profit
done by each salesman here we want to
highlight the rows in the table wherever
profit is greater than four thousand
select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting select
the option new rule from the drop down a
new formatting rule dialog box appears
under select rule type select the option
use a formula to determine which cells
to format
under format values reference box enter
the formula as equals if Open Bracket
dollar sign H2 greater than four
thousand comma true comma false close
bracket
this will apply formatting to a cell if
the profit is greater than four thousand
click on format button
from the format cells dialog box select
the fill tab from the color dialog box
select the color as green
finally click ok
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than four thousand are
highlighted with the green color
logical functions evaluate a cell or
cells for a criteria and returns a
Boolean value true or false
in this topic we will cover various
logical functions like if and or not
true false
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to determine the commission
percentage of each salesman
following is the criteria if net sales
greater than or equal to ten thousand
set commission as five percent
if net sales greater than or equal to
5000 and less than or equal to ten
thousand set commission as 2.5 percent
if net sales less than five thousand set
commission as one point five percent
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function
let's write the formula in cell I5
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function e if and then type an open
parenthesis the first parameter we need
to pass is a logical test here The
Logical test is if sales cell G5 greater
than or equal to ten thousand assign
value as five percent
then we will pass the second logical
test here we will use and function if
Open Bracket and Open Bracket sale at
cell G5 greater than or equal to five
thousand comma cell G5 less than or
equal to ten thousand comma assign value
as 2.5 percent
in the else parameter we will type 1.5
percent this means that if the first two
cases become false then the formula will
assign the value 1.5
finally close the two braces for the two
IFS thus Excel Returns the result as 2.5
percent for cell G5
now drag the formula with the help of
the fill handle we can see the results
for the other cells as well
the or function returns true if any of
the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
in the given table we are required to
assign performance remarks for each
salesman as per the scaling table
in scaling table we have the criteria
that if net sales greater than 10 000 or
profit greater than 5000 set remark as
good
else set remark as needs Improvement
let's write the formula using IF and or
to check sales and maximum sales in cell
J5
so our formula becomes equals if Open
Bracket or Open Bracket G5 greater than
ten thousand comma H5 greater than or
equal to five thousand comma double
quote good double quote comma double
quote need Improvement double quote
close bracket
let's drag this formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
this formula returned true if any of the
condition is true thus in the given
example the cell j9 returns good even if
profit is less than five thousand
our next function is true false true
slash false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell
the not function reverses the result of
the function
if result is true it returns false else
true
let's write formula as equal not open
bracket K5 close bracket in cell L5
this Returns the result as false
let us now study about different lookup
and reference functions used in Excel
such as vlookup hlookup match index and
offset function
the vlookup function lets us search for
specific information in the current
worksheet
say we have a list of students with
marks we can search for the marks of a
specific student if our table is in
horizontal format and we want to
determine a specific value then we use
the hlookup function
consider the extract from our Master
sales table
the table depicts sales information
based on order ID Products sold salesman
and net sales now we want to determine
the net sales corresponding to order ID
let's understand how we can accomplish
this using the vlookup function
note that vlookup function is only used
for vertical tables let's use cell I2 to
add the formula
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function name
vlookup and then type and open
parentheses
now we will add the arguments the first
argument is lookup value lookup value
corresponds to the value or item we are
searching for
so in our example it will be order ID
1121 cell H2
the second argument is table array table
array is the cell range that contains
the data in this example our data is in
cell B2 to e40.
the third argument is called index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be
four
the fourth argument is range lookup this
value corresponds if we are looking for
approximate matches or not and can have
value either true or false true denotes
the approximate match and false denotes
the exact match here we will pass false
finally close the parentheses
so our function has the form equal
vlookup Open Bracket H2 comma B2 colon
E40 comma four comma false close bracket
we can see that the function Returns the
value as 2 2 7 7.
note that the vlookup function works
from left to right that means the lookup
value should always be present in the
leftmost column of our table array
if our table is in horizontal format and
we want to determine a specific value
then we use the hlookup function
consider the given table let's write the
formula in cell I4 we will start with
the equal sign then type our function
name
hlookup and then type open parentheses
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be order ID
equals one one two one
cell eight four
the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G8 to
as11.
the third argument is row index number
here our table array net sales is the
fourth row so our third argument will be
four the fourth argument is range lookup
here we will pass false finally close
the parentheses
so our function has the form equals
hlookup Open Bracket H4 comma G8 colon
as11 comma 4 comma fault close bracket
the function Returns the value to 277
note that each lookup function works
from left to right that means lookup
value should always be in the topmost
row of your table array
the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then Returns the
relative position of that item in the
array
let us understand its functioning with
the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell E5
type equal sign
then type the function name
match and then type an open parenthesis
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be date in
cell B5
the second argument is lookup array
the lookup array is a range of cells
that contains the value we are searching
for in this example we will select the
cells B17 to b1342
the third argument is match type match
type can be either -1 0 or 1. the value
should be 1. if we want to find the
largest value less than or equal to the
lookup value
the value should be zero if we want to
find the first value exactly equal to
lookup value
it should be -1 if we want to find the
smallest value greater than or equal to
lookup value
here we will pass the match type as 0 as
we require an exact match
finally close the parentheses
so our function should look like match
Open Bracket B5 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
B dollar sign one three four two comma 0
close bracket
this Returns the value as three now we
can drag the formula across cells with
the help of the fill handle
similarly we can use the match formula
in cell E3 to determine the position of
the shown field name cell C3 in range
B17 to I17 for example net sales is at
seventh position in the range B17 to I17
let's write the function in cell E3
write formula as equal sign match and
open parentheses in the first argument
select cell C3
for second argument select cells B17 to
I17
past third argument is zero finally
close the parentheses
so our function looks like equal match
Open Bracket C3 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
I dollar sign Seventeen comma 0 close
bracket so for profit loss field the
value returned is 8.
net sale the value returned is seven
the index function Returns value from a
specified position in a specific column
in a list
suppose we want to determine the value
of a field mentioned in cell C3 from the
sales table on a specified date
the table should dynamically fetch the
value if the value of the cell C3 is
changed
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
if we write net sales in cell C3 then
formula should fetch net sales value for
specified date
so let's use the index function to
determine the value in this worksheet
select cell C5 write formula as equal
sign index and open parentheses
the first argument is the array for our
example enter B17 colon i1342
the second argument is the row num this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter E5 which denotes the required date
the third column is column
this corresponds to the column number
that has the value we want to return
here we will enter E3 which denotes the
position of the field name in cell C3 in
table
finally close the parentheses
thus our formula Returns the value as
6528 based on the position at cells E5
this is the net sales value on the date
the 2nd of January
now drag the formula with the fill
handle to the other cells as well
the offset function returns a reference
to a range that is the offset number of
the rows and columns from another range
or cell now let's understand how to use
it select cell D5
right formula is equal sign offset and
open parentheses the first argument is
the reference this denotes the starting
range from which the offset will be
applied for our example we will select
the reference cell as B17
the second argument is the rows this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or A negative number
so for our example we will enter E5
minus 1. here we are subtracting 1 to
match number of row which have the value
and the offset from the reference cell
the third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name and subtract by 1 to
match with the offset referencing
finally close the parentheses
the function Returns the value based on
the position of date from cell B5 and
field from cell C3
now drag the formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
a variety of statistical functions are
available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test binomial or
chi-square
in this topic we will cover various
statistical functions like sumif
countifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and median
sumifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
sum based on one or more criteria the
sumifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain criteria
let's understand how to use the function
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table say we want to
determine the net sales done by salesman
Justin
here we will use the sumifs function to
calculate net sales so let's write the
formula in cell N4 type equal sign then
type the function name sumifs and then
type an open parentheses the first
argument is the sum range this is the
input range that contains the required
data so in our example we will select
cells H4 to H 1328
the second argument is the criteria
range this denotes the range that
contains the required criteria here we
will pass the range that holds
salesman's name sales E4 to E 1328.
the third argument is criteria this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require net sales of the salesman
Justin so we will select cell M4
finally close the parentheses note that
we can pass multiple criteria in this
function the function Returns the net
sales done by Justin
countifs function Works in a similar
manner like sumifs it counts the number
of cells in a given range when certain
criteria is met
say in the given sales table we want to
determine the total number of sales for
net sales greater than 8 000. to
determine the count we will use the
countifs function so let's write the
formula in cell N5 type the equal sign
then type the function name
countifs and then type in open
parentheses the first argument is the
criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales H4 to h1328
the second argument is criteria one this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require entries with net sales
greater than eight thousand so we will
enter greater than eight thousand
finally close the parentheses
note that the function allows you to
enter multiple criteria cell N5 reflects
the total number of sales as 445 for net
sales greater than eight thousand
in this topic we will learn how to use
the function's percentile quartile
standard deviation and median in Excel
consider the given sales table let's see
how to use the percentile function on
net sales to find its 40th percentile
select the cell n6 write the formula as
equal sign percentile Open Bracket
select the column net sales H4 to
h1328 as our first argument
pass the second argument as 0.4 in order
to find the 40th percentile
this Returns the result
5220 this means that 40 percent of the
net sales is less than or equal to 5220.
the next function is quartile
quartile function depicts the results
for the first second third and fourth
quartile
say we want to find the total number of
sales which are less than or equal to 25
percent let's use the quartile function
to calculate this
select cell N7 to write the formula
type equal sign function name is
quartile and open braces
select net sales column H4 to
h1328 as the first argument
type 1 as the second argument
the second argument must be a number
between 0 and 4. the function Returns
the value as
3822 which means that 25 percent of the
sale is less than or equal to 3822
note that here we can use the percentile
function to perform the same task the
function percentile H4 to
h1328 comma 0.25 gives us the same
result it's up to us which function we
would like to use for the quartiles
Excel has a function to calculate sample
standard deviations stdev
[Music]
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean
say we want to calculate the standard
deviation for number of customers
so write the formula in cell N8 as
equals
the function name stdev
open braces
select number of customers columns as
its argument
the function returns a result 1.4
the median function Returns the value
from the range for example we want to
find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in cell N9 write the
formula as equal sign the function name
median then open braces
select net sales column as its argument
this calculates the mid value of net
sales as 6192
rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in a
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function Returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales
select cell j4 and write the formula as
equal sign then type the function name
rank and then type in open parenthesis
the first argument is the number
this is the value whose rank we are
required to calculate here we will pass
the argument cell H4
second argument is ref
this corresponds to the array or
reference list here we will select the
column net sales IE cells H4 to H 1328
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and 1 denotes ascending
order
this argument is optional if we don't
pass any argument Excel automatically
takes the argument zero here we will
pass zero finally close the parentheses
here we can see that Excel has
determined the rank for net sales
7164 as 553
finally we can drag the formula and can
see the rank for the other cells based
on net sales
let's embark on this transformative
adventure together having said that if
you're an aspiring business analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple lens postgraduate program in
business analysis from cardio University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be a right option for
more details use the link in the
description box below
in this session we will start with
certain exercises which we will perform
in Tableau in order to understand some
basic concepts
now in order to learn Tableau the basic
first step is to import a sample data so
in our case what we have done is we have
imported a sample Superstore which is in
Excel format a sample superstore.xl
which has three worksheets in it orders
people and returns
so by importing this data into Tableau
first of all we will create
relationships between these sheets in
order to identify who all have placed
orders and how many people have returned
the orders we will do some analysis on
the orders placed by certain set of
people and Order returned by certain set
of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders
table the order sheet on the
relationship canvas here okay and you
can see the data sample data the first
100 rows over here
okay then now we need to create an inner
join with people's table between order
and people okay so if you see
it has automatically detected the field
names on which the inner join has to be
created so on the order side you have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people data
so if I close this box and go and check
the people's data
foreign
so see the region and the person these
two columns from the people table have
now been
joined with the orders table right so it
means that these are the orders in a
particular region which has been placed
by
in this region
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by customers
across multiple regions
south west of USA South Region west
region then you have a list of order IDs
which have been returned so basically
the order ID in the returns sheet
matches with those orders in the orders
table
and then you have the people
sheet in which you have region
and a person associated with that region
the sales person associated with that
region okay so basically when we are
combining joining orders with people we
are joining that
which orders
belongs to which region and who's the
sales person associated with it so what
we have done over here is we have made a
inner join means all the orders should
belong to particular region and that
region is in the people's sheet
and then in the second step
now we will make a
left join between returns and orders
not in a join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the
order ID
okay so just edit this
click on left
and
select order ID as the join column now
what does left join means left join mean
is that consider all the orders from the
orders table and only consider the
orders from the returns table which have
data means which are returned otherwise
show null for the order IDs which are
not returned so if you see this is the
these are the two columns from the
return statement and these are null
because this is relevant to the order
IDs which are not returned okay which
has been accepted by the customer but
these are the orders for which you see
data in the returned and Order ID column
it means that these have been returned
now with these joins in place please
save your book and now we have our
relations created in the
um
in the Tableau now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model
now we'll move to sheet 1
okay
and first we will place
state
and person on the rows
sheet okay
then
I'll go to my
numbers and
put the profit or D so per state per
person how much profit I am making as a
company okay this is my goal to check
now sort by highest to lowest
so California is giving me the maximum
profit of seventy six thousand six three
hundred eighty one then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I have
listed my profit in descending order
now I can also check what are the number
of orders
placed
and check the distinct count
so out of 120 out of the total orders of
127 okay so this is the number of total
number of orders which have been
returned for California is 127.
it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as per
the revenue as per the profit and this
is the details of the orders which have
been returned per state
so if you see for connected for a Kansas
there are zero returns
so you can also extract data
foreign
ERS and identify new rows using order
date so as and when new data is being
added you can
refresh it now say extract
and now you can save this information
profit
by state
and click save so this is the extraction
of this particular report which is
possible in tableau
so this is the first exercise which we
have completed for
reviewing and analyzing the profit per
state highest to lowest and within that
per state what are the number of orders
which have been returned by all the
customers the distinct count of order
IDs which have been returned
now let's start our second exercise on
creating calculated fields in tableau
now in this exercise we will be doing
certain
activities like we will be creating a
set to show the states which have more
than 100 customers then we will be
creating a calculated field to show an
average sales per customer okay then we
will create a calculated field to show
the sales goals and then show emerging
and developing stage so these are the
four kpis which we have to derive
now the first thing we have our sample
Superstore data already imported and the
relationships created in a join with
people and left joined with returns
now we have our sheet 2 in which we will
create the states a list of states which
has more than 100 customers
so what we have to do is we have to
click right click on the customer name
and click create
set
okay
now we have to give the name as states
with 100 plus customers
and then go to the condition tab
select by field
and then apply condition as
count of customer name
greater than equal to
and click
ok
now we have this set created states with
100 plus customers
now to determine average sales by
customer
we have to now create a calculated field
so go to the analysis and click on
create calculate field
okay
now name it as
average
sales per customer
and now we will say average
we will use a
foreign
that per customer we are using a level
of definition function include which
means that per customer what is my
average sales right we've already used a
function aggregated function called
average so we are saying per customer
give me the total and then give me the
average per customer so we're going to
click ok
now create another calculated field you
can also create from here
and name is as name it as sales goal
now in this we are going to type the
formula if
minimum
States
with 100 plus customers equal to true
then
sum of
sales
into 1.3
else
average sales per customer into
100 so me we are saying that
if the customer belongs to the set of
states with 100 plus customers then the
sales Target should be
1.3 times the actual sales as of today
else it should be 100 of the average
sales per customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging
or developing state
if distinct count
of customer name
is greater than equal to 100
then
the state is tagged as developing state
yeah
else it is called as
emerging state
okay so we have now
three calculated Fields average sales
per customer emerging or developing
State and sales goals
now we will use this in our reporting
so we will drag sales goal under the
columns
and then I'll drop my state
so now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or not
then add your customer name
make the measure as count distinct
and make it as discrete
okay so if you see this
we have the count of customers per state
and the
the sales goal
for that particular state
and now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want
which is there per state
now go to show me and select
this particular chart
bullet graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales access and select
swap reference line fields
now from your left hand panel drag and
drop emerging or developing State on the
color panel
okay so a merging state is the orange
one and the developing state is the blue
one
and save the sheet as
developing and the emerging States
so if you see this it's an emerging
State because its count is less than the
customer count is less than 100
its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is
19511 okay
so now this is a developing State its
count is greater than equal to 100 and
its sales goal and its sales is exactly
the same it matches so that's why you
are saying the bar and the blue bar is
ending exactly where the vertical bar is
foreign
so what we are trying to depict is that
whether the state is going Beyond its
Target sales goal or it's behind it
and you can see that using this
particular vertical bar like for example
Michigan its sales goal is 71 952 but
its actual sales is seven six seven two
seven zero average sales so that's why
it is be above its Target
and it's a developing state
because it has more than 100 customers
so you can even sort
by the count of
the uh customers higher to lower so all
your developing state will group from at
the top and the emerging States Will
Group at the bottom
or you can sort by
the sales goal
so the orange bar is the sales goal or
the blue bar so depending what sales
goal
has been
derived for each state
we are going to take example of the
Netflix database which we have and we'll
prepare certain reports in order to
identify what kind of reports we can
generate from such a data set
So currently on my screen what you can
see is the Tableau the Netflix data
sheets the data sources where you have
the Netflix shows movies their
Associated duration what kind of shows
or movies are there their release here
are the associated rating description
and key which is the show ID now this is
the unique identifier for each show in
this Netflix title sheet and with this
show ID all other sheets are related
like you know who are the directors of
the show in which country the show was
released
what is the cost of each show all that
information is in this sheet and to
which particular category basically the
listed in category is being listed in
this particular sheets so what we're
going to do is first we are going to
import this sheet into tableau
okay and then create relationship
between them using the Tableau
relationship canvas
so first our the primary transaction
table the sheet in which all the
information related to movies is there
or shows is there is in Netflix titles
and then we will drag
sheet like Netflix cast titles cast now
Tableau has automatically identified the
relationship between the show ID of
titles and show ID of titles cast and it
has made a join
so if you double click this
you can see this relationship
cardinality and the related fields
similarly I'll drag
titles category
countries and directors
Now by virtue of this all the sheets
have now been joined with Netflix titles
and with this relationship ready we can
start preparing our reports
now let's create a basic report where we
can just glance the data like you know
whatever we were seeing in the Excel how
it looks in tableau so you have all the
types of movies then
for example I drag the release Here
now first I do not want to consider it
as a
Dimension so I'll just
release year or category per type there
is a release Here and then I'll drop the
listed in
so now these are the categories so per
year the the details of the categories
right and then you can
drag the title and the associated rating
so this is just a view of your data
we can name it as shows listing report
now let's try to create some report for
some
measures some numbers
Etc
so now let's check in which country how
many movies or titles were released you
know what is the count
so first let's drag the
country
so as soon as we dragged the country
uh
field it is identified that it has the
geographical names and identified the
latitude and longitude details so
Tableau internally does that
automatically and it has identified the
spots across the globe of the relevant
country
now let's drag the listed in on the
color section
now what it is doing is it is showing in
which country what different kind of
uh category wise movies are or shows are
being released like in Sri Lanka
documentaries have been released in
India action and adventure United States
action and adventure like this
now let's
put
account of
the titles right so if you see 247
action adventure
movies or shows have been released in
United States
okay so this is one inference by this
particular report you can
identify
so let's save this report as
listed
in
by country
okay now let's create another report
we will call it as the per year
statistical report in this first I'll
put the release years in the column
now
count of Netflix titles so this is the
count of Netflix titles per year 2017
2016-14
and then count of Netflix titles in the
countries
this is the second bar chart okay now
what I'll do is I'll combine it into one
so one report
we are
moving in the bar creating the bar and
one in the line now I just have to
so we will click on the count of Netflix
titles by country right click Market
dual access
so now as soon as you click click this
both the charts have been combined and
right click over here and say
synchronize access
okay
okay so now if you can see see right in
2017 you had uh 2 303 Netflix releases
across all categories and one one five
nine
titles right one zero six three titles
in 2017. so this is a descending
representation of the count of titles
release per year across category and
across titles
so let's call this as
per year
stats
now let's create another report
number of shows
per title okay
so or or sorry per rating so we will
drag the rating column
and
we will
count of titles
unique count of titles and unique count
of show IDs
okay
one is bar and one is line
so this is a report which shows rating
wise titles and the show IDs
so in the tooltip you can see the
listing count of Titus and show ID for
rating
okay so let's call it
shows our rating
now let's create another sheet call it
as
shows
by cost
so in this
what we're going to do is first drag the
cast column on the rows section you have
name all of all the cast and then we
drag the
show ID on the column section and put a
count d
and sort it okay
you can remove the null cast
and this is your
sorted order and on the labels section
you can say show Mark labels and you
will see the count that don't pump care
has done the maximum then Shahrukh Khan
om Puri nasruddin Shah so this is the
details on this sorted order that who
has done how many shows okay
then next is
shows by director similar to shows by
cast
drag
director into rows
or differently if you want to prepare
into columns and then count off
show ID
okay sorted
and you can actually filter out the null
director value
and this is the account put the label
so you can see Jan's Twitter has the
maximum shows
okay
then create another report
shows by category
now similarly drag the listed in
in the rows and show ID count
remove the null category
and sort
labels show Mark labels so International
movies are the highest category dramas
the next comedy International TV shows
this way
you have your category
now let's create a dashboard in which we
want to bring combine all these reports
and
take a common view so first let's drag
listed in by country
then
shows by director
also please let's set the size as
automatic
then let's drag shows by category
and shows by cast
now these four reports are on a single
dashboard we will link them to each
other so go to worksheet actions
add action
filter
select dashboard one
only select shows by category here
and in Target dashboard one
except shows by category keep everything
else
and in the source sheet just select
click select
click ok
now whatever category you will select
over here
that related category data will
automatically be shown in other reports
like see International movies across the
globe across countries directors of only
International movies who has done the
maximum
Johnny Tow and uh shows by caste right
that who has done the maximum
International movies or dramas
or comedies
travel has a maximum number of comedies
and then if you see the comedy movies uh
you know these are the count of comedy
movies released across the countries and
the who is the director
another a very interesting report which
you can prepare is that for example you
want to check in which country maximum
duration of
uh your
maximum duration of
movies have been released so
first let's create a measure
remove this
okay
so if you see
maximum duration of the movies or the
entire Netflix content is maximum United
States then in India these many minutes
next is United Kingdom and you can also
change the colors
whatever you feel is as per your
standards or as per the convention you
can change the color combination
so there are multiple ways you can
generate reports and uh hope you have
understood how you can leverage such a
data to create your reports
so let's discuss what's in it for us
today
now we will first talk about why power
bi you know why it's a popular tool and
what problem it solves what is power bi
and what are the primary features of
power VI which you can use in your
day-to-day data analytics visualizations
creating fancy reports creating
meaningful intelligent reports
for your organization for your personal
use for crunching numbers for generating
reports real time Etc
now the most popular tool for power bi
is the power bi desktop uh I'll show you
certain uh aspects of power bi desktop
and then I'll show you the steps how to
install power bi desktop on your machine
and then definitely power bi desktop is
a free tool provided by Microsoft but
then you can also subscribe for an
Enterprise version which is primarily
used uh by Enterprises for publishing
their data uh so we'll see the
difference and then overview of our
dashboards which can be created uh you
know what kind of dashboards can be
created in power pi
so this is the agenda for us today
now why power bi so generally uh you
know visualization tools reporting tools
are required in order to create and
prepare and analyze meaningful data it
could be a data for an organization it
could be a social media platform data it
could be a data from iot devices but
something which needs to be analyzed and
some intelligent inferences and data
mining has to be done on top of it now
imagine there is today we are in a world
where terabytes of data and information
is getting generated on an instantaneous
basis on minute-by-minute basis so it
becomes very essential to churn out
something meaningful something
intelligent out of it in the market
there are a lot of other tools which are
available like clicks uh all tricks
Tableau and power bi so power bi is a
Microsoft product which is one of the
most popular products and it comes as a
free to download product Microsoft power
bi desktop which is available and I'll
show you a couple of ways how you can
install it on your machine but why power
bi is uh popular is because it provides
a lot of out of the box features drag
and drop features which we will talk
about in our subsequent sessions and you
know classes but today's session is
primarily focused on giving you guys an
introduction on what is the purpose of
power bi and what all problems it solve
uh in the in the real world so power bi
allows you to view analyze and visualize
huge quantities of data and the data
could be in any format Excel CSV text or
it could be a direct connection to a
database like SQL MySQL Azure Oracle
anyone IBM db2 so it supports n number
of uh you know data types or data sets
and it's very powerful in terms of data
connectivity
so it uses powerful compression
algorithms to import and Cachet the data
within the dot pbix file so it's as
convenient as a simple software if
suppose you import a data and then you
prepare a report and then you can easily
share the reports with your peers or
someone who's co-developing with you
either through Power bi cloud services
or even you can share the pbix file in
an email
or through any other means and you can
share the data set with the concern and
they can then work on the report
independently so there are different
ways there is no uh kind of a limitation
for you know working on power bi there
are multiple ways and it is very fast it
is the most fast uh tool to work with
Excel because definitely Excel is also a
Microsoft Technology so it works very
fast on Excel based data and gives you
numbers and Reporting at a very high
speed
so now once you have imported the data
power bi allows you to model the data
allows you to work intelligently on the
data it allows you to model data in a
way that if you are importing data from
multiple Excel sheets importing data
from multiple tables you can easily
create a relationship between those
tables or data sets in power bi and then
create visually appealing reports
meaningful reports as I've been
emphasizing and make sense out of that
data no data in silos is of any use data
in Silo means a single worksheet or a
single data set will not churn out any
meaningful information until unless you
basically join it Club bit merge it
Union it append it with some other data
sets because a single data set will
never be able to hold that much amount
of information which is generally
required for a you know important report
so it has easy drag and drop
functionality with features that allow
you to copy all formatting across
similar visualizations so just like in
Microsoft Excel we use format painter to
copy the format of one cell to another
similar features very very similar to
excel products or Microsoft product they
have provided that if you have applied
uh a particular thing on a report you
can easily replicate that on any other
report the font uh the header size the
background color you don't need to do it
again and again so there's a lot of
reusable features which are also
available okay now
as I said Excel is a Microsoft product
power bi is a Microsoft product so they
have intercompatibility you can publish
data from Excel to power bi now with the
latest developments and enhancements
as of today pixel has also plugged in a
new feature called Power pivot which
I'll uh show you later down the line but
that also allows you to do a quick
analysis no you can't create of course
complex reports or uh fancy reports like
power bi but Power pivot allows you to
create you know quick measures quick
functions quick calculations on your
data quickly only in Excel so it's an
Excel plugin but whereas you know you
can power bi is also compatible with
Excel so when you create a report in
power bi it gives you inbuilt feature to
export your power bi report into Excel
format directly you don't need to do any
programming for it also
you can easily publish when you publish
your power bi reports it allows you to
give some inbuilt intelligence of
analyzing your reports in Excel and it
gives you all those of all those
features of exporting your power bi
reports into Excel which is not
available in any other tool or otherwise
those tools have to create plugins
create add-ins and probably they might
charge for it but Power bi comes with
lot of out of the box features which are
very very helpful for analyzing data in
Excel and vice versa
Azure Cloud now Azure itself again is a
Microsoft cloud Tech stack so using
power bi with Azure allows you to
analyze and share large volumes of data
so Azure basically Azure database or
Azure Cloud servers are meant to hold
huge amount of data and power bi allows
you to have seamless connection you can
easily connect to Azure data Lake
you can reduce the time it takes to get
insights and increase collaboration
between business analysts data engineers
and data scientists so azure
data Lake becomes the central focal
point where all your analysts Engineers
can keep working on on the centralized
piece of data and churn out their
reports data scientists primarily job is
to keep the data in a structured way
optimized way optimize the input output
operations disk operations and memory
utilization so that the reports also get
churned out in a faster manner so every
uh you know every person has their own
role in order to give a quick
refreshable report a quick rendered
report any report which is taking huge
amount of time to get rendered will not
eventually be used by the business users
because then it does not solve the
purpose the report should be fast
reports should have uh you know
appropriate filters slices and dices you
should be able to you know create the
reports or dynamically or you should be
able to analyze visualize the data
dynamically so all those visualization
features are available in power bi and
it works seamlessly either it is small
data or huge data it allows that you to
work on those kind of data in a seamless
fashion
right so this is just a very uh quick uh
example of how our typical dashboard
looks like dashboard is nothing but you
know you have clubbed a couple of
multiple reports on a single page and
you know if you change a filter uh a
single filter on the page all the
reports will honor that filter and the
numbers will change accordingly so if
you see the in this example there is a
filter or a drop down or product ID
product name employee name or supervisor
or a date range so whatever date range
or filter you will apply all the reports
on this dashboard will get changed based
on the filter you have selected so power
bi allows you to get insights from data
and turn insights into action to take
data driven business decision and that
is the ultimate goal of any
visualization tool that is the purpose
for which visualization tools are bought
uh and purchased by the organizations
and data is fed into them
Now power bi fetches data from Factory
sensors social media sources to get
access to real-time Analytics so that
you are always ready to make timely
business decisions so so basically there
is a a feature of live connection or cut
off data connection so either you can
work on data which is residing on a
machine and you can just work on the
cutoff data like for example it's
there's a data which is available for
sales 2017 2018 and you're just working
on a historical data it's a cut off data
or it could be possible that you want to
be connected live uh to a real-time iot
based sensor based data or social media
data like Twitter Facebook feeds or you
know you're connected to live Google
worksheets that is also possible you
just need to publish your Google sheet
for a public domain embed that you are
in into Power bi and then whoever
updates that Google sheet automatically
the power bi report will also start
honoring and consuming the new data
which is added in the Google sheet so
all those kind of real-time streaming
analytics is also possible and that is
one big feature and very important
feature of power bi which is widely used
and has a very huge uh you know Market
acceptance and Market utilization
now what is power bi
power bi is a business analytics service
provided by Microsoft that lets you
visualize your data and share insights
right so earlier
you know uh
Microsoft used to have a technology
called ssas now they have replaced
actually ssas and SSRS with power bi so
basically you can use power bi on the
data which is there in your Excel or any
other data source and the power bi
service or power bi desktop basically
creates a connection to those data sets
and import it cache it and give you a
handle to it in order to work with it so
you can create these fancy meaningful
visualizations like for example there's
a geographical map if you are importing
data for a country or a continent or a
region power bi will automatically
detect that it's a geographical
information and give you a map with
latitude longitude information and you
just need to plot uh your uh your
numbers on the map either you can use
bubbles or or either you can use
triangles or whatever data structure you
want to use but all the mapping will be
available geographically then you can
create pie charts which is shown in this
visualization you can create dream apps
you can create cards where you know you
can highlight the most important numbers
like sales total sales of your company
across all the regions or the growth
chart or the month on month uh you know
sales of your organization or number of
total number of products or units sold
so whatever is important and to be
highlighted for the management to take
any meaningful decision or any insights
you want to share power bi visualization
tool the power bi visualization uh
uh chart allows you to drag and drop and
create wonderful reports okay
so what are the features of power bi so
power bi desktop is something a
standalone tool which you need to
install on your machine it allows you to
build reports by accessing data easily
you do not need Advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report though yes it is beneficial that
if you know some SQL programming
analytical programming or you are aware
of advanced features of any analytical
tool that might help you but that's not
a showstopper you can easily build
reports in quick turnaround time without
needing any technical background you
just need to have some analytical uh
mindset and you can create uh Savvy
visualization and you know analytical
reports
stream analytics as I mentioned you can
create a live connection uh with any
kind of data it could be iot it could be
media social media it could be Google
Docs it could be uh you know any other
kind of uh you know live connection it
could be a live database connection
itself so any insertions or updations or
deletions happening will automatically
reflect in your report
yes multiple data sources and that has
to be the primary criteria for any tool
to be popular if any visualization tool
is limited to certain data sets then you
know it will not be highly acceptable in
the market
and custom visualizations right so as I
showed you certain uh examples in the
past in the previous presentation uh
that feature is very important because
someone might want to look the kpis look
at the kpis from a different perspective
some management might want to look at
the kpis from a different perspective so
you need to you need to have that
capability to create different
visualization from the same data set now
let's take a look at how
to install power bi desktop on your
machine
so basically what you need to do is
you need to go to this URL
power bi dot microsoft.com en US desktop
okay
and you need to just
enter this
now you can download it for free so just
click over here and
it will open Microsoft store so
basically now what Microsoft have done
in the latest operating systems is that
when you are trying to download you can
actually directly go to the Microsoft
store
and search for Power bi
so let's wait for a couple of seconds
right here so power bi desktop in
Microsoft store for me it's already
installed so it's asking me to open it
I'll open it in a while but for you for
anyone who is not installed he will see
the button of install over here and it
will automatically install in your
machine and then you can easily go and
open power bi desktop now if I click
open over here
now this is the
uh UI of the power bi desktop
I'm not going to go right now in
creating reports right away we will talk
about that in a subsequent session with
sample data sets and we will cover the
features of power bi desktop one by one
but this is what it is this is the whole
tool of power bi which is having the
visualization pane all the different
visualizations are you know can be
created from this pane
then this is the pane which allows you
to select the data data fields then
there is a report view data View and
relationship view the data model view
where multiple relationships you can
create you can view the data in the grid
of the tables which you will create and
the reports so you can create multiple
reports on multiple Pages you can keep
adding pages either you can drag create
multiple reports on a single page and it
will become a dashboard or you can
create separate independent reports on
the single page
and these are the menu options which we
will talk about how you can change color
scheming you can do data modeling you
can create new reports and you can also
transform data which is the biggest
feature extract transform and load the
data apply different logic changing data
types massaging the information creating
new joins appending the data you know
adding new columns etc etc uh we that is
what you can do in transform data so
this itself is a whole different world
it's a dedicated topic so we will talk
about that in our subsequent sessions so
what's in it for us today we will be
learning how to connect to data
different data types data files like
Excel PDF then what are the different
data importing modes and then I will
also show you practically different sets
how to import them in power bi and use
it for your visualization purpose now
what are the steps to connect to data so
now we will go directly into Power bi
and try to import one by one few most
commonly and popularly used data sets
which are most commonly used in a
day-to-day activity rest of course there
are power bi supports n number of data
sources but we will do something
practical on the most popular ones so
let's let's open our power bi
now this is my power bi and first I want
to show you that how can I import data
directly from a web page and import the
data now it is asking for a URL in order
to import data so what I have done is I
have created a Google Excel sheet with
simple data with rows and columns and
what I have done is I have shared this
sheet as published to web
okay so you just need to say publish to
the web the link as web page and
say done it's it's automatically
published and say link so copy the link
which you have published on the web copy
this link
and then go back to your tableau
paste that link over here and click ok
Now power bi will try to establish a
connection with this Google doc sheet
because it's published on the web
you need to wait for a while while it is
reading
okay now it has read one of the HTML
tables I'll select this one now you can
see it has it is showing me a preview of
the table which is there on my
Google sheet right it has 11 rows so it
has all showed all the 11 rows so now I
can go and transform this data because I
can see my headers are there starting
from the second row so there's an
opportunity for me to transform the data
so I'll go and transform it so that it
looks clean
okay so first is I need to remove the
first row which is the
null row remove the top rows
okay and then I need to use the first
row now as a header so you just click
this option use first row as headers
that's it so now if you see my row ID
order ID order date ship date all my
data is now ready so I can say close and
apply
click apply changes
now this is an example of web data
import you can go and preview your data
right now the biggest advantage of this
data connection is that it's a live data
so for example I insert another row
let me change the order ID
some some I've sub change some basic
stuff and I
it's Auto saved
Ctrl s now I'll go to my tableau and
I'll refresh
now you can see as I refreshed my
power query editor I click refresh all
and I got my new row which is there in
the live data I got that fetched from my
okay I got that row the row number ID
number 12 so I have to say close and
apply
now you can see the new row the row
number 12 is now available in my new
data set in the data set because it's a
live connection it's a live connection
with the web based Google sheet okay so
this is one
important way in which you can import
data
now let's try to import data from a text
file
now I have already prepared our text
file called
sub categories Dot txt
now let me just open it in a notepad now
it's a very plain simple file tab
separated file in which you have product
subcategory ID subcategory name and
product category key so basically to
which product category this particular
sub product belongs to right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go back to
my get data option
and I'm gonna select text slash CSV
option
and I'm gonna select option mod product
subcategories Dot txt
okay so now power bi has identified that
it's a tab delimited file it has
recognized the headers
Etc right and I can now directly load
this file
okay
so now once the data is imported in
power bi it is like
irrelevant to me it's a composite data
in in Port I'm doing right so in my
presentation when I'm talking about
importing data there are different
importing modes right import our data
import can happen through different ways
okay
one is direct query mode in which I
create a live connection to the database
which I'll also show you uh using MySQL
and Ms SQL server and also you can do a
composite mode in which you can have
data imported from Excel plus you can
have direct query modes so you can have
multiple uh modes to connect and create
a composite data model and that's what
we are doing right now in our practical
so what we are doing over here is one we
have imported data from the web second
we have to imported data from a text
table
now after doing text now our next task
is to import from CSV let's try another
one so now I have imported product
subcategory now I'll import
a CSP file so again I'll choose the
option Text slash CSV and now in this
CSV file let me open this CSV file and
show you what it is it
so this is a list of all my products
product key products sub category Key
Products stock keeping unit Etc a simple
CSV file and I'm gonna import that
okay so now it is identified the
delimiter is comma rather than a tab and
it has already recognized the headers
correctly so I load it
okay so now my products are there
product subcategories are there for
product categories now what I have done
is I have created as Excel mode now so
now Excel I am using to import my
product category
so now I have to click on the option of
import data from Excel and I'll say
product categories
select the sheet load
and now so my products product
categories product subcategories do with
different uh data storage types but
still now the data is imported into
Power bi it is a composite data model
now another very important data type
which you can import is the PDF also
right so what I have done is I have
created a PDF called customers my
customers data is lying in a PDF so what
I've done is I've created a PDF
which has data for some columns are
there like you know customer key prefix
first name last name birth date marital
status gender email address annual
income total children etc etc so this is
the data set
which I have created in PDF so what I'm
going to do is
I'm going to select PDF now
and import customers.pdf
and see it has recognized my table on
page one which I'm gonna load
okay
you can rename this as PDF
table
okay so this basically these are the
different type of
data
types we have imported PDF Excel text
CSV and web page
now let's take a look at another
interesting data set which you want to
import is the my SQL Server data set
so what I have done is I've already
installed MySQL server on my local
instance and there's already a schema of
SQL live tutorial over there and I have
certain tables already
prepared over there like Department
employee Etc so my goal is now to import
this data or create a live connection
with this data set
now in order to import
my SQL database Connection in power bi
you need to First
download a
connector MySQL power bi connector so
you need to go to this link
and then click on download and install
the MySQL connector based on the
operating system you have you click on
download and install it
after you have done this go back to
Power bi
and then give
the IP address of the database in my
case it's there in this local machine
and the schema which I want to import is
SQL live tutorial so I'll give the name
click connect
okay now it's connected so now it is
asking me which particular tables you
want to create a connection with I am
choosing department and employee
and I'm just loading them
okay so now this is the exact data which
is there in the employee and Department
in MySQL okay so this is one example of
how to create connectivity between power
bi and MySQL
now I want to do the same thing using
SQL Server Microsoft SQL Server so I
have also installed Microsoft SQL server
on my machine
and I have used the SQL Express so this
is the name of my server so which I'll
copy the server name
and
go to get data
select SQL Server
and for now database is optional I can
say direct query click ok
now it is showing me what all tables I
can import so in my SQL Server tutorial
in my SQL Server I have
I have these three tables customers
employee attrition Olympic events so I
can use probably the customers one which
is
now you can see this is the data the
customer's data which is lying in my SQL
Server okay so I can preview it and load
it
so now you can you can preview the data
in uh Power bi that is this is the data
so I can rename his customers from
mssql
and this is from
MySQL
and
okay so now
this is not the only data
sets you can import now if you take a
look at the options which power bi gave
what different type and variations of
data it can it has compatibility to
import from
okay so we can just take a look at the
categorization on the left hand side
first there are five ways like Excel
text XML Json is also possible you can
evenly directly import an entire folder
and within the folder whatever uh data
types of files are there it will detect
it PDF power key or even SharePoint
folder which is itself or Microsoft uh
technology then different kind of
databases SQL server and MySQL we just
saw but it's not only limited to this
you can connect to Microsoft Access
ssas Oracle database IBM db2 postgres
cybase teradata and then sap
databases Amazon redshift Impala vertica
Snowflake and N number of databases
which are there in the market today
Amazon
Etc
then it also allows you to connect with
its own power platforms power bi
platforms data mods power bi data flows
dataverse Etc Azure there are different
kind of storage
mechanisms in Azure and Azure itself is
a Microsoft Technology so it has a
compatibility of a lot of azure uh based
data storages like Azure SQL database
blob storage uh Azure data breaks right
Azure HD insights path so if you have
those kind of services running on your
observed cloud services you can even
import them over here
now online services like you know you
have erps running uh or some data which
is shared on the internet if you want to
import it uh that is also possible
through certain products uh Dynamics 365
Microsoft Exchange online Salesforce
Google analytics Adobe analytics GitHub
LinkedIn sales if you want to do some
analysis of some social networking uh
you know feeds that also you can import
and then other miscellaneous are also
their web-based hive R script python
script if there's something to import
get data from uh Google Sheets like we
saw one example in our video right now
so there are multiple options available
now once you have imported the data
which is relevant to you in our
subsequent sessions we will see how to
create relationships but just giving you
a glimpse that whatever data you are
importing power bi Auto detect certain
relationships and it will create for you
but then you can go and manually also
change so this is the composite data
model which is getting created in the
back end while you are importing the
data you can easily go and manage these
relationships either keep them as is you
can delete and create new ones manually
so there is no limitation in that
so this is what we have witnessed we
have imported data from different files
types data types and then you know we
have tried once it is imported into uh
Power bi then there is no limitation of
how you use it you can create
visualization across different data sets
and then create your
standard reports
so this is the example of importing data
from web importing data from a database
from a PDF
and then once you have data you can
shape and combine data you can basically
do what whatever transformation you want
to do you want to uh make joins merge
the data so for example if we go back to
our power bi and if I go back to my
transform data section
now as I have now different data sets
available with me I have I can do any
kind of you know operation
transformation on the data right uh
so like I showed you I uh upgraded the
header row because one of the imported
data was not showing the header
correctly uh or this columns like this
exact one column is extra I can remove
the column
right all those Transformations whatever
I do in the back end gets captured in
the applied steps section right
this is the customer data you can create
uh you can merge it you can append it uh
you know with other data sets right
looks for example I want to create a
merge data set of my categories and
subcategories so I can say mer selectors
two data sets and say merge queries as
new
and
I can select product categories and
products are categories select
product category key on both the sides
and then they do a left Auto Zone so
whatever product categories are there
I'll get the subcategories associated
with it and I'll create a new table
which will have
now I have the table which has the
category and the subcategory and
subcategory in one table itself so I can
rename it now to as
category
sub category
table it's a it's a merge basically it's
a join between category and subcategory
now I have a common table right and I
can close and apply
so imagine I have created a
new table which is imported created from
one data set is which is Excel page
another data set which is text based
see this category subcategory table so
now I can use it
the way I want in my visualization
reports so that's what the presentation
says right that once you have uh the
imported data you can shape you can
combine you can adjust you can do
whatever transformation you want to do
and create your visualization okay so
what topics we are going to cover today
we are going to talk about different
types of data modeling and the most
important part
and aspect of data modeling is the
cardinality the cardinality which you
basically decide after reviewing the
nature of data and after you've imported
it what kind of cardinality you have to
basically highlight right and there are
different type of cardinalities which
you might have heard earlier also if you
are from PL SQL background like one is
to one one is too many Etc we will we
will talk about that
now what are the different types of data
modeling now dimensional data modeling
is one of the most popular and most uh
you know widely used uh modeling in
dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers
Etc that will change less frequently as
compared to the sales transactions
because transactions are happening every
day every minute so sales is a more fast
changing data set in dimensional
modeling which is in the terminology of
data uh is also called as a fact and
customer store product which are like
more of static data and less changeable
data is sometimes called a diamond
attention so this is a typical
dimensional data model which is
typically used uh sometimes right and
then there is another model which is
relational model this is a typical model
which we have been using in database
design like you know primary key foreign
key relationships so for example you
have a customer who has purchased a
product so probably he might have the
customer might have the details of the
product which is processed and you will
make a join between customer and product
table and even you can make a join
between product or product type or
customer or product types customer table
will also have a key to the product type
so this is less conducive for reporting
but it is more of a transactional
relational model but of course this is
also feasible but from the power bi
perspective when we talk about reporting
and visualization this is the most
extensively used dimensional data model
and this is what we are going to see in
our example now so what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna show you certain data sets
first we will prepare and create certain
offer data sets and then we will Import
in our sample power bi file and then
slowly slowly we will create the
relationships
now one important thing which you need
to understand that in power bi if you go
to Power bi there is an option that that
power bi Auto detect new relationships
after data is loaded and import
relations from the data source on first
load so for example if you are importing
the data from a database where you have
already defined the primary keys and the
foreign key relationships so uh that is
the first option which power bi will
Auto detect and secondly if suppose you
are importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is CSV and if
power bi detects a common column key
columns it will auto detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship
menu manage relationship menu in power
bi which I'm gonna show you okay so if I
open a power bi and this is where the
option lies go to file
go to options and setting options
data load
and these are the two options which are
by default check you can uncheck it and
auto and manually prepare relationships
there's no limitation to that but if you
uh keep it checked then power bi will do
its job to detect the relationships okay
now coming to the next important factor
cardinality
now before I start playing around with
my data and start showing you certain
relationships it's very important to
understand these four types of
cardinalities one is many to one right
so basically
many to one means that many orders
contain data of One customer so per
order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one-to-man relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many-to-one
relationship
okay
second other cardinality is one is to
one one is to one relationship is only
applicable when you are saying it's an
extension of the current table so for
example in one table you have employee
details and you are extending the
details of the employee in another table
like employee address employee ID so
that is like one is to one there is no
multiple records of a single employee in
the address table only one employee ID
exists right
now one is too many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one okay so
in customer table only one customer
record exists per customer and one
customer can place many orders for
multiple products and can also have
multiple delivery addresses so that way
this is a typical one is too many
relationship we will be seeing this
example also in our sample data set
and last is the many-to-many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you practice practically and in our
case we will see that like for example
you have placed an order for a
particular product uh you know but there
are multiple fulfillments which has
happened so suppose you made order for
10 products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically you the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order ID might have a multiple
fulfillments for the same order ID so
there will be a multi many to many
relationship which I'll show you
practically so now with this background
let's
start importing our data now the first
important thing which we need to import
is the Master data so first I'll import
all my master Dimensions which are uh
which I'm going to you know use in my
example so first is the customers table
customers data
so this is the customer details the
customer key prefix first name last name
birth date marital status and gender
some redundant columns are also present
but we'll remove it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes
okay so now this is my customers data
with the relevant columns and the key
per customer customer key
now there's no relationship in this
model right now right because only
single table is there and the associate
data is only imported now let me also
import my another important master table
is the products
select the products data product key
product sub category product SKU product
name model name product description
color size so just see all the relevant
information only specific to the product
is available so I reported
okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales table
now I I'm assuming that power bi have
Auto detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
power bi what relations power bi has
Auto detected let's first say check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click this
join now what it has done is it has
created a join of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
place many orders right and that is that
it is detected by the quality of the
data and the data sampling which power
bi has done you can also reverse this
relationship here I can select customers
and I can select sales now it has become
one too many so that you can also do
manually so that is what I said whatever
power bi is detected it is up to the
description of power bi internal uh
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's
change the relationship so one is too
many means from One customer and many
sales orders
similarly let's see what has happened at
the product site
of the relationship
similarly power bi many sales orders for
one product you can for simplicity's
sake you can say products
sales
product key is the join now just focus
one more thing please also see the the
column on which the join is is the grade
column grade out column product key is
also here and product key is also there
and it is what we wanted so one is too
many relationship from product to sales
table and act
now looks fine this is something which
is looking logical and probably now we
can
proceed further to create a report
now let me explain the cross filtering
with an example
now for example I want to check in a
report
that what is the count of products which
uh which a particular customer has
ordered
okay so what I'll do is I'll select the
product count of product name
now if you see
the and for each customer in front of
each customer name the count is coming
as 293 293 it is getting repetitive
because because there is a one-way
filter Direction filter between
customers and sales and sales and
products right so this join
is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go here
I'll first open my sales table
we can also open it here let's make
click it says okay now if I click OK you
can see the single arrow is changed to
Double Arrow it means it's a it's a both
side filter
So when you say a both side filter it
means that implicitly within power bi
you can imagine that all the product
columns now will get appended because of
both ways filter you have applied and if
you go to your report now see the change
of the numbers now for T20 so the total
count of products across all my
customers come out to be 293 now the
report looks uh correct if I change the
relationship from back to single between
product and sales then you can't make a
join between customers and products
basically you can't derive the product
count from the product table see this
if you have to live with it then you
would have to go to the sales table get
the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct
okay
so if you want a report in which you
want the count of product name
and even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the
direction of the filter which is from
single to both so this is a typical
example they where you want to use a
two directional filter
now let's proceed further and import
other data set in order to show you
another example
now I want to show you an example of
one is to
1.
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is there
so I'm loading the customer details now
you see it has Auto detected a one is to
one relationship
what is the meaning of one is to one
means One customer key only has one
entry in customer details there is no
multiple entry so if you click this
button
it's a one is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now easily
associate a
email address with the first name you
will get one is to one
record
so now you can see that with one is to
one relationship
with the first name I have Associated
the email ID and for each email ID
there is a Associated first name method
so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count
so in this report what we have done is
uh if you click over here so the first
name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one relationship
and then
and if you drag
the customer key
report takes time to render and even if
you can
so this is the reporting output you have
the customer key first name associated
email address and the count of product
names uh which the customer has ordered
now this is an example of 1 is to 1.
now I want to show you an example of
many too many now for that I'll import
my
fulfillment data set
huh
okay now in my fulfillment data set
there is a column for
order number so basically what I'll do
is I'll drag order number from here to
here
okay so now what has
um
uh Power bi detected
I'll do one thing I'll select sales over
here
fulfillment over here and order number
to odd number
okay so it's a many-to-many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order now
many-to-many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for both ways
cross filter detection uh a Direction
but you can you can check that but
definitely uh Power bi shows a warning
that this relationship has cardinality
to many to many and this should only be
used if it is expected that neither
column contains unique values okay so we
know that fact that's why we are
accepting this relationship as many to
many because we know there are multiple
order numbers over here in the sales
table which are mapped to the multiple
order numbers in the Fulfillment table
we'll click ok
now you want to keep uh the uh
uh direction as both ways or One
Direction that is up to you the way you
want to map the report so I can double
click over here
and you can even click so now you can
select from which way single filter you
want from fulfillment to sales or sales
to fulfillment I'll prefer sales to
fulfillment and click ok
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to shortlist one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many too many
now if I show you further relationships
which you can keep on adding like for
example I have uh the example of
territories
now in which particular territory the
sales was done
I put over here
okay so now it's a typical one is too
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you have
uh details of returns
now this is another transactional table
which is about the orders which have
been returned rather than being you know
returned by the customers so you have a
product key
and so automatically power bi has
detected a relationship between the
product key and the product uh table
right and even if you can join the
territory key in which territory the
return has happened
right so mostly the most common
relationship which you will observe is
the one is too many because
as I told earlier the most common
relational model is the dimensional
model uh the static data the slow
changing Dimensions the scds are the
master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I
talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the territory stable sorry the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data model now so far what we have done
as per our last session is that we did
data modeling on the different data sets
which we had imported in power bi like
products sales data returns fulfillment
customer details and customer Master
data calendar details Etc so in the last
session we prepared a data model and
established the relationships between
these different data sets like one is to
one one is too many many to one one is
to one Etc and we saw the examples now
once our relational model is prepared
our data model is prepared now our next
activity is to create certain additional
columns which we want to derive basis
the data which we have imported
so for example I'll start with my
product data set now in my product data
set I want to introduce a column which
basically
categorizes that if any product which
has a color uh you know red black or
gray I am going to tag it as a colored
product rest I'm gonna say not a colored
product right so all these are like
example of byte type product skus so for
that now in order to introduce a new
column you just need to do what you need
to select the table in the data grid go
to the table tools and say new column
okay so column will get appended to the
rightmost part and you will start seeing
a uh formula section typical to like you
get in your Excel now I'm gonna say that
the name of my column is going to be
byte type color okay and I'm just
creating a if condition if
product
color
is equal to
black
okay
or
or if it is equal to red
or if it is equal to
Gray
then
say yes it's a colored product I'll say
no
okay so now you can see this is the
product color red and black they are
saying by type color Yes blue is no
multi is no etc etc so this is a classic
example of an if and else condition
based conditional column
okay so you can create such columns now
second column custom column which I want
to create is I'm going to call as
discount
now this is the pricing of my products I
want to associate certain discounts
which I am ready to give to my customers
this is the product category like what
is the pricing of the category again I'm
going to use make use of if else but in
a nested way so if I am saying if my
product
price is less than 100
then I will give
zero percent off
uh zero percentage of discount so 0 into
product price just to keep it consistent
now I am saying
else
if less than 100 and 0 else I'll check
again that
if
the price is
less than
500 then I'm ready ready to give one
percent discount
on the product price
else
I'll move further so like this
I have created a formula
so what I'm saying is if product price
is less than 100 give zero percent if it
is less than 500 then give one percent
less than 2 000 then 1.5 percent less
than three thousand then two percent and
otherwise else less than three thousand
if a two percent else three percent
right now after this column is created
now you can check right so this C the
product price for this particular
product it is less than 100 so that's
why there is no discount it is uh
between 100 to 200 then this has been
given a one percent discount so like
this all the discount column is now
calculated now this column is available
just like a regular column in my product
table
now after this I'll go to my sales table
now in sales table I want to identify uh
create a column called as cost
there is no product cost column over
here so that will be derived
so let's create a column
called as cost
and it is derived by order quantity
into now the cost of the product
is in the product table and I know I
have already created a relationship
between product and sales table
so I just need to select the product
cost column now only keyword which I
have to use in power bi is the related
keyword so this will pick up the
relation
and now for this particular sale order
the cost has already been derived so
this order number this is the cost for
which uh the product is is the costing
of the product for this particular order
you do
okay
now I'm gonna create another conditional
column over here called as
order status
I'm saying if
any order whose order quantity is
greater than 2
then for my organization it's an urgent
order
else it is a
normal order
oh sorry
lost it
so this is my
order status column and I have my order
quantity
urgent or normal
so any order which has order quantity
one is normal any order which is having
order quantity as greater than
2 is
urgent you can see this
so there's a this whole power bi
tabs and sheets allow you to also review
the data what you're doing so it's very
convenient
now
I have my sales data now what I want to
bring within the sales is my discount
column so here also I want to bring the
discount which I have created
so I'll say discount
[Music]
will be order quantity
into
related
product discount right so the discount
calculated column which I had created
under products I'll bring over here
now I am creating the order level
discount so if you see for this
particular order there's a 25 uh
uh you know for 25 rupee discount at the
cost is hundred thousand rupees okay
and what is the order price now so I
have taken the order cost the discount
now I have to create a column call as
price order price so that will be
again order quantity
into related
price which is per product
price enter
okay so now I have the cost the discount
and the price right available with me
now I want to
calculate the total
uh
total revenue total profit and loss
right
per order how much
so first I'll calculate per order how
much revenue I am generating so now I
have to generate a column called as
Revenue
revenue is price
minus discount
so 1700 minus 25
1700 minus 25 2071 minus 42 and if I
want to calculate the profit per order
then it is
Revenue
Minus cost
okay so now you can see you know typical
custom columns calculated columns which
we have created are all playing around
with the number numeric values numeric
data primarily and trying to give
inferences into per order cost discount
per order price revenue and profit so
typical calculation columns which I have
prepared in front of you
now let's take a look at other different
variations of custom columns I'll create
certain columns for text based custom
columns calculated columns using Text
data
so I'm now moving towards my customer
table in which I have customer key
prefix first name last name birth date
marital status and gender
now I want to create a new column in
which I want to derive the age of each
customer as of today right so I'll use
another function a date function called
as
date div
now date div so I want the difference
between the birth date of the customer
and as of today
in years
okay so this customer as of today 68
year old one is 74 68 57 Etc so this is
one derivation of a calculated column of
age
let's take another example now this is a
text based column where I want to
derive the full name of the customer
now here I'll say first
lowercase in lower case I'll concatenate
the prefix
then ampersand
space
ampersand
first name
Ampersand space
ampersand
last name
and closing brackets
Etc
full name
okay so this is an example of full name
in low cases
now another
calculated column conditional column at
the customer level
I want to identify a flag which says who
is my Target customer base is the
demographics shared over here Target
customer
so I'll say
if
the marital status is equal to
m
and
total children
hurry
and total children annual income
so okay so let me change the logic a bit
so marital status is M and
age
is
less than
these customers are my Target customers
okay so I would say
yes
else no
see this
he's a marital status is married Logan
Diaz and age is less than 50 else
everyone so if I try to filter
so these are the my Target customers
69 out of 1178 so this is just a
conditional column but a logical
condition an example which I am trying
to highlight over here
okay now
let's look at certain calendar
date oriented columns calculated columns
very typical like now I have a simple
date column now I'll keep adding certain
columns which are you know which help
you which will help you understand how
we can uh
you know do some calculations on the
dates so like for example I want a date
which is 12 days after the current date
the date in the column so just simple 12
Days After
select the date and add 12.
now if you see the date format you can
go and change the format at the top
and if whatever you feel like like this
now see 12 days after first Jan 2015 is
13 Jan 2005. you can go and change the
format and other details
let me also show you if I go to my cost
and other columns I can go and change
the format this is like a currency cost
is currency so I can go and
select the
change the currency type and you can
even show the dollar value or whatever
currency type it is
so for numbers you can do currency or
text or dates you can select the format
so this is available at the column tools
level
now in customers
like we had our
column of full name so now what all
things are available format as text okay
data type text so very minimal options
are there with date you have options of
the date format
now next
I want a column which defines the expiry
date okay so eight months prior
to the
expiry date with this which is coming up
in eight months so I'll create a column
called as eight months expiry
and then there is a e date function I'll
use that I'll use my
date in the data set
comma I'll say eight so now this date
column will append eight months to my
actual date and again I can go and
change the format
correct
now another important column like I want
to know the date name
so I'll use a function called as
format
and I'll select my calendar date column
and I'll say give me the DDD
format of it so it will give me the day
name the day the day name of on that
particular date
next
years in between
so I want the years in between the
today's date and the date of my calendar
so equal to
D Def
the calendar date
comma today
comma year
end
seven years 2015 to 2022
then last date of the month
so if I want what is the last date of
this particular calendar month
I will use a function EO month which is
there and label in the
power bi so I'll say
last date of the month
equal to
e o month
then
just select the calendar CSV date
comma
0 in months and enter
change the format
then similarly start of the month
so I'll use a function called start of
month
so for for all January dates end of the
month is 31st Jan and start of the month
will remain 1st of Jan
change the format
foreign
next I want to know what is the weak
number of that particular date so now
there is an inbuilt function called
week number week num and just pass the
date and you will get
the weak number first week of the year
second week of the year Etc
now another very
good example is whether the weak
day is a weekday or a weekend right so
what is it's a weak type okay
so I'll check I'll put a if condition
and there is a function called weekday
and I'll pass the calendar
if it is less than 6
it means it's a weekday as it's a
weekend
so all Saturday
and Sunday D names will come as weekends
or else everything else will come as
weekly
so these are very different variations
of different column types calculated
columns which is a very important
utility and uh and any Bravo bi project
you will definitely be ending up
creating n number of calculated columns
to derive your numbers to prepare your
reports but it's important to understand
what all things we can do yes there are
n number of functions available in power
bi but uh what I have tried to Showcase
over here is some important functions
but basis your utility basis your
problem statement you can look up for a
relevant function in the power bi
dictionary
now with this
introduction to calculated column this
is the base for us to now get into our
next session where we'll be talk we will
be talking about creating dacs measures
and Dax functions we will be using power
bi Dax functions which is much more
powerful than simple uh calculated
columns where you can do more uh complex
calculations uh you can calculate totals
and then use them in the reports so for
that we will look up into our next
session let's embark on this
transformative adventure together having
said that if you're an aspiring business
analyst looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities are in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learn sports.jet program in
business analysis from Purdue University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be a right option for
more details use the link in the
description box below we have reached
the end of this session on full business
analytics course should you need any
assistance PPT project code and other
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and a team of experts will be happy to
help you as soon as possible until next
time thank you and keep learning stay
tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign